there's something gooey on my keyboard
curious um oh yeah it's coming hi
oh good sorry guys for the delay on the
video today and also sorry that it's
this kind of quality video and I'll so
sorry that I keep saying sorry so much
yeah I have been on four flights today
I've been traveling for over 24 hours I
mean in another hotel room yeah the
luxury I'm in another hotel room for a
secret project that I swear it's getting
announced very very soon um and it's
gonna be really fun I'm just so tired I
haven't slept I've been on so many
planes
I've inhaled recycled air full of
strangers farts and both of my lungs
carry-ons my carry-ons my check baggage
both of them got lost by two separate
airports so currently I'm in a place
I've never been before
and I don't have any clothes or
underwear or socks or hair things
oh no I'm reaching revelations on new
levels of disaster
so I'm delirious right now I'm gonna go
to sleep I'm sorry I'm I'm sorry I'm
still I'm not gonna
I might label this girl has stroke on
camera get all the views I need a shower
that's a priority because I'm going to
be around strangers stranger danger
really means when a stranger smells like
body odor not that they're gonna hurt
you in a violent way educational
experience these videos are hope you
guys are doing really well frier ii will
be back at some point tomorrow but
probably later in the day tomorrow
um because i have a lot of stuff that we
are doing for the secret project all day
and so I won't get a chance to edit till
tomorrow night but you're cool your face
is looking like it's still there I
watched a lot of Game of Thrones on one
of my flights felt a lot of weirdness
mix that with watching a lot of um
what's the one with the zombies oh my
god my brain is so dead you know what
I'm talking about
umm now I just want to think about it
now I'm just taking time I watched a lot
of things that made me really
uncomfortable in a small space so I'm
feeling real fun look at his hair this
is the hair of a sane functional human
being have a great Thursday whatever day
it is for you guys just say goodbye
I don't know walking dead